[inaudible]
let's talk about all the ways not to do ketosis.
Oh,
we're gonna knock over all of them because there are certainly more ways to fuck
up ketosis than to do it properly.
So we're going to touch on some of the more common ways that people mess it up.
Ketosis is a fasting physiology.
All right,
and if you are going to mimic that or get into a key topic state through diet,
there are a few points I would make.
First,
I'll say how to get into Ketosis or how I get into ketosis.
Typically these days,
how I get into Ketosis is I will for a day or to have one meal per day at night,
large salad,
plenty of cheese,
oil in some type of fatty meat and like beef,
steak,
something like that.
But one meal less than a thousand calories for sure.
It's going to be a relatively small salad,
one meal a day for one or two days.
And I made then and very typically fast,
right?
You want to do this with some supervision,
medical supervision,
don't do it without getting cleared with your doctor first,
fast for a day,
and then during that day I'm going to drink copious amounts of water with a
little bit of salt in it and I'm going to walk for at least three hours that
day.
I'll do that while making phone calls,
listening to podcasts,
doing whatever I need to do or want to do by that point,
end of the day.
And certainly the more you get into Ketosis,
the better your body will become equipped with mitochondrial machinery and so
on.
That allows you to get into ketosis more quickly,
assuming you do it for extended periods of time,
uh,
that at that point,
probably that night or the morning after sleeping a lot is also very helpful
because it can be pretty miserable being in the gray zone between normal diet
with carbohydrates and ketosis.
So I'll really try to get nine,
10 hours of sleep if I can.
I will wake up and I'll most likely be around 1.2 millimolars in Bhb,
let's just call it ketones,
ketosis using a device called the precision Xtra,
x t r a by Abbott labs.
You want to use those instead of the piece sticks because the piece sticks can
be misleading.
When your body gets better at processing ketones,
it will appear that you're not in Ketosis when in fact you are so as much as you
might dislike it,
you use the finger pricks.
I had to do ketosis with high protein.
Low fat doesn't work.
You can look up something called rabbit starvation if you want to see how well
that works.
Doesn't work very well.
So you need to be consuming,
and of course there are exceptions to everything I'm going to say,
but to keep it simple,
70 to 80% of your calories from fat,
that is a lot of fat.
Okay,
so you need to consume the fat.
That is your primary macro nutrient.
Other mistakes,
eating too much food.
This is one of the most common.
So they're like,
I'm eating all the right foods.
I don't understand why it's so hard for me to get into ketosis.
I'm only at 0.4 millimoles and I'm doing all the right things.
It's because you're eating too much protein.
All right?
Or are you eating too much in terms of vegetables,
but people will sit down and back.
I can eat anything I want lily to big rib eye and they're like,
oh my God,
I'm Attica.
Kurtosis.
Yes,
it's because you ate too much protein and then through a process called
Gluconeogenesis,
your liver is going to take that excess protein in effect and converted into
glucose.
All right,
so don't eat too much.
Portion sizing is really important.
This is what I realized years ago for myself.
Instead,
if I want to maintain a deep level of Ketosis,
small meals,
generally speaking,
all right,
another mistake which leads to people failing after say a week cause they just
can't stomach the food after all that like,
ugh.
God,
I feel like a human cheese cloth is that you don't have to get all of your fat
in your primary meal.
And this was a tip from a scientist named Dominic D'agostino who I've
interviewed on the podcast.
You can check if you search Tim Ferriss Dominic.
Then he'll probably pop right up and what he will do instead of just putting oil
and she is on everything that you eat,
which gets really tiring after awhile.
He will have say a soup like a creamed spinach soup before his meal and then he
can have a meal that appears to be mostly protein and vegetables because he
already got this fat bomb in the form of a creamed spinach soup.
It's really about having them close together,
but they don't always have to be a entirely together.
Another mistake that some people make when they're trying to get into ketosis.
I mentioned walking,
doing a lot of walking and they will do intense exercise lifting,
things like that in an attempt to break down muscle glycogen,
which they will do very effectively and then they will flood their bloodstream
with glucose,
stopped doing kettlebell swings,
stop lifting weights and just walk and I bet you'll be at 0.7 tomorrow morning.
So those are a few guidelines for more effectively getting into into ketosis are
many ways to do it incorrectly.
Dominic D'agostino,
Peter Attia,
there are many,
many folks out there who have done a lot of research,
a lot of testing end used,
ketosis.
You used a ketogenic diet while exercising very intensely,
whether for power or for endurance.
So those are a few guidelines that have helped me and I hope that they help you.
And remember,
Tim Ferris is not a doctor,
does not play one on the Internet,
so get proper medical,
super efficient.
Ketosis is not for everyone.